this refugee crisis hasn't happened in
europe on this scale since world war ii
and
the pace of the crisis in ukraine
shifted very quickly
in 2015 the refugee crisis when syrians
and afghans were fleeing conflicts and
coming into europe it took three months
to reach the one million mark this
reached the one million mark in a week
i'm zane vasravi al-jazeera's
correspondent in eastern poland and
between us this refugee crisis is on a
scale that i've never seen before
[Music]
in this conflict the level of violence
perpetrated by the russian military
as part of the invasion force ratcheted
up very quickly and it surprised
everyone
[Music]
when the strikes on keith began
everybody started getting out
and so that created a bottleneck that
took days to pass through that's gotten
much better the times at the borders are
being measured in hours not in
kilometers anymore a lot of warehouses
have been opened up for
big groups of people they're sleeping in
cots there's no privacy there's hundreds
and hundreds of people to a room so it's
still pretty dire but at least they're
not outside in the cold um waiting to
cross over like over in the early days
one of the most heart-wrenching cases
was a father from kharkiv who was
dropping off his family and then going
back to car key
nice one
[Music]
that is a city that russia's military
campaign has almost completely leveled
it's difficult to sort of listen to
the people sort of tell their stories
and talk about saying goodbye that was
definitely one that had us all
i'm wiping away some tears during the
interview and during the edit that's
definitely a time when the producers the
cameraman it's difficult to sort of have
to go through the process again
we'd crossed into ukraine into one of
the border towns there at the ukrainian
side of the
border control there was a family with a
woman on her knees begging a passport
control officer to let her husband go
through who was just shy of 60. they
were all screaming and solving the
husband who's crying as well they're
trying to console his family knowing
that he would have to go back and they'd
have to go on without him because of the
conscription rules and their son who
couldn't have been more than like seven
eight or nine just started shrieking and
screaming now he wasn't old enough
probably to understand everything that
was happening but he was old enough to
understand that
if this woman had passport control
didn't let her father through that meant
his life was immediately in danger
fear that propelled them to run for
their lives is now very quickly turning
to anger the hope is switching from
desperately seeking humanitarian relief
and escape to
desperately seeking
more military capacity to keep fighting
the russians
the women and children are leaving to
save the future
the men are staying behind to make sure
they have a country to come back to
the hope is to get kids to safety and to
stabilize their day-to-day lives somehow
but there's also a parallel hope of
being able to have the capacity they
need to keep fighting and eventually
push russia back
you